yeah my dad though he has some had
creative ways to punish me though that
do it has some funny-ass ways this will
used to do this thing back in the day or
he would stick out his fists and tell me
to punch my own face
that's a Korean thing and the unknown a
lot of Korean friends that had to do
with name [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] is
what kind of sadistic [ __ ] is that dude
like punch your own pace my brother had
ice bats my mom would do ice baths and
throw them in there that's like some
military [ __ ] why that takes time you
gotta make the path you gotta fill it
with cold water you have to throw
[ __ ] ice cubes in there and then
throw your naked kid in there you know
what we call that we call that a
commitment to rage because most people
during that whole 20 minute ordeal they
would have calmed down by then yeah they
would have calmed down by the time I
went to the store I got all that ice you
know I went to the 7-eleven I checked it
out I came back home got into the car I
would have been done with I know and I
just would have had a bag of ice for no
[ __ ] reason but you know Japanese and
Korean people they're like I'm gonna
stick through this that'll teach em yeah
like I about dude I can remember how
many times I got my ass beat it did you
did you ever get like beat by your dad
and then sometimes when you have
confrontations at school and these kids
would throw punches that you're like
they should know your heart bro yeah
like I nothing is as scary as yeah a
parent Oh beating I was like you're a
little baby fist
it feels nothing like a bat to my ass
just to put just to put it in
perspective I think I was more scared of
my uncle and like other people too
because my my parents were pretty crazy
but not like them
that's so weird with Asian people - how
your people who aren't your direct
guardians could kick your ass and it's
okay like at the church the church is
there like thankful yeah yeah like the
church members could kick my ass like
what the hell like I'm not say ever
I have no safe house oh my god we get in
trouble at church and now we could slap
upside my head by some stranger and then
he would tell on me to my parents like
your kid did this nice funny then I
would just slapped up the head again I'm
like yo this is not a safe place I
thought a church was supposed to be a
safe house
it's kind of stupid to like they don't
know how to explain things but if you
noticed like a lot of Asians don't know
how to explain things and think because
a lot of people didn't they didn't have
to dating get explained things yeah it's
just it's literally like robots like
George's oh it's like this is common
sense
so you should know already and then I'm
gonna just teach you the hard way Wow
yeah and then you grow up saying well
[ __ ] yeah you shouldn't be doing that
then you do it to the next generation
but no one knows what they're doing so
there's a lot of stupid Asians if you
think about it right like yeah yeah
you're stupid as in like people don't
know how to reason they're just what
they're just they have really good
discipline they know what they're
supposed to do yeah but it's everything
is automatic and there's no deep thought
behind it yeah so you can't really
explain it it's kind of like how we
memorize math uh-huh like you you can't
explain it but then like for us I grew
up learning a rhyme for multiplication
and like they'll tell they'll tell you
but then they said just memorize it
first it's easier uh-huh
so you go throughout life just
memorizing different things not knowing
the meaning behind it yeah yeah there's
some times to like I wonder I wonder if
I'm I wonder how my parents remember
things versus how I remember it oh yeah
and they tell their story in my story I
was completely different
I had this recording that I'm trying to
find somewhere in the house where I had
an argument with my dad about the the
the color of the room that I wanted to
paint so we recorded it so check this
out so I so we had this argument where
we were redoing the house so he redid
redid the outside my dad likes to fix
things sometimes he does a great job
sometimes he does it but it's his hobby
and he was allowing us to paint our room
whatever color that we wanted what do
you mean by whatever color that he
wanted it means the color that he
approves that's the freedom of choice
yeah that's the freedom that I had at
the house so this conversation is so
funny I wanted to paint my room a dark
blue as you can see as an adult I did it
yeah a dark blue and with white trim
that's what I liked I want it I wanted
that and then my dad goes no that
doesn't make sense
why what do you mean because I like it
he goes no it's not good I was like how
is it no I'm sorry I'm [ __ ] up the
story he says it's wrong that's what
that was the word that took it is wrong
to do it he goes it's wrong
like what do you mean it's wrong I was
like you asked me what color say that in
Korean or in English he said in both cuz
he could speak English yeah yeah yeah
and if I if he feels like I'm not
understanding what he said what he's
saying in Korean he'll say it in English
but I understood what you're saying in
Korean yeah you're just saying you're
just pissing me off in two languages so
he goes it's wrong I was like what do
you mean it's wrong he goes you can't
have this is his words because a dark
color is heavy right you can't have it
on a light color because it's light
because it's like it's crushing it so I
was just made that [ __ ] I made that [ __ ]
up on the spot I guarantee it that you
crafty [ __ ] and he goes well you
can't have dark colors you can't have
heavy colors on light colors and I just
look like what are you talking about
all these homes outside have a dark
color and then white trim what are you
talking about I've rarely seen light on
top with dark home but I've never seen
it till this day and he was saying that
and I was telling him no that's I don't
even I don't even mentioned you have
white trim panels yes and in like a
color on top to border it out and so and
I I told him this I didn't tell him that
part all I told was like it's an opinion
how can my opinion be wrong you asked me
what color I liked and it was it's wrong
you know what you're saying you're
telling me that my opinion is wrong and
I had he had the silver tape recorder
yeah and I wanted to record it I was
like fine I'm gonna record this
conversation I'll show you how stupid
you look
and so I hid that tape recorder and he's
just it's just a tape recorder of being
him yelling package of all my I'm
looking for is it one of those small
ones were you also the one so I'm
looking for that tape recorder so I
could listen back to our argument when I
was like 9 years old with me and my dad
and it was just something so stupid you
know why our parents never learned
reasoning like in the sense of the
Western sense of logic yeah yeah and be
so like if you think if you think about
the way they reason right like they
don't reason with facts yeah a fact to
them can be their friends opinion yeah
or what they choose to believe like it's
not scientific evidence and they to them
like scientific evidence is as like
wishy-washy as someone's opinion to them
it's it's in the same like they don't
care if something can happen over and
over and over and there's evidence yeah
that weighs just as much as my friend
said this too and he thinks that like
that's why their mind is not clear of
what has weight and what doesn't there's
that's so hard to conversate with them
dude there's a lot of things that I've
picked up from my dad for example that
habit of always trying to win an
argument even if you're wrong that I
learned that I did that I did that when
I was younger a lot I started to realize
yo I'm arguing with this girl
not because so it would be on some [ __ ]
of I know I'm wrong but you got a win
and you know when it finally clicked
trying to get rid of